an arrest warrant is out for an alabama
corrections official suspected of
helping an accused murderer escape vicki
white and inmate casey white left
lauderdale county jail together on
friday the two are not related janet
chamleon reports on the intense search
for the two fugitives
we have had a warrant issued for
director vicki white
the charges are permitting or
facilitating an escape in the first
degree the alabama sheriff searching for
escape capital murder suspect casey
white now says one of his own
corrections officers was in on it
vicki white lauderdale county's
assistant director of corrections faces
a felony charge carrying up to 10 years
in prison and a 15 thousand dollar fine
she'd been with the department almost 17
years four times named employee of the
year white submitted retirement papers
last thursday friday was to be her last
day
this is not the vicky white we know a
sentiment echoed by her mother pat davis
i doubt she never even had a speeding
ticket but i mean she's always been what
i say a good person
and
like i say this is all a shock the
sheriff says law enforcement has
received tips on a possible getaway
vehicle
authorities are also reviewing jail
footage and call logs i think over time
their relationship
changed and the lines between offender
and correctional officer were blurred
mary ellen o'toole is a former fbi
profiler and says inmates like casey
white can be seen as powerful
manipulators especially because
corrections officers learn to see their
humanity outside the context of a crime
scene what is a concern here with a
person with his record he's a career
criminal he's a very violent man she's
in grave danger for cbs mornings i'm
janet shamlean